now showcased in his new book I
exaggerate my brushes with Fame are
Jamie wax spoke with Nilan about his
formerly hidden talent Jamie good
morning it looks like a good one it's a
good one Michelle good morning along
with SNL Neelam was a long time star of
the Showtime series Weeds and has
appeared in several films and is a
frequent guest on TV talk shows and very
popular with talk show hosts and all
along the way he's made more than
memories of the fellow performers he's
met he's captured more than a few and
Brilliant caricature
so these are some of your sketchbooks
from the years yeah yeah there's a
family with their dog I started adding
color after a while that was our waiter
in the tularies Kevin Nealon's art has
long been familiar to friends and fellow
performers I'm gonna do my best now
Conan like his pal and former Saturday
Night Live colleague Conan O'Brien okay
now still because the nose is the
hardest feature to draw all right all
right
this is years ago probably back in 1989
or 1990 and I noticed that Kevin was
sketching me and
um I started to take my clothes off he
said no it's not that kind of sketch uh
we did that later well and it's
beautiful but he was sketching me and
you included that sketch in the book
yeah uh it's very unflattering but you
can see his talent you gave me a very
long broken nose the book is I
exaggerate my brushes with Fame a
collection of musings memories and
kneeland's Incredibly detailed and Vivid
caricatures I mean these are amazing
caricatures of people kneeland's
subjects include a wide range of
celebrities from Jim Carrey to Eddie
Vedder to Dave Chappelle and it all
started with a napkin that was maybe
eight years old and I went to the
commissary once and there was a I think
a napkin some guy pulled it out and he
drew a caricature
just a funny cartoon of a like a guy
with a hat on and a big nose and you
know lips curled up and I was somehow I
was really taken by that and I kept
drawing that picture and as I got older
I started drawing more and more which he
also used as a soothing mechanism
I'd like to sketch people on planes
because the guy see one D uh-huh you
know I travel first class I mean that
was a good trip I had claustrophobia for
a while so if a plane got stuck on the
tarmac sitting out there I had a pad
with a pencil and I start drawing and
that would take my mind off just pushing
through your Panic yeah
the Artistry in this book was formed in
part by pushing through the pandemic
when Neelam was locked in with his wife
comedic actress Susan yeagley and their
15 year old son you know I couldn't do
stand up so this is a non-verbal way of
getting laughs right and creating and
creating and they're just you know I
mean some of them will make you laugh if
you know who the person is Conan do you
have any favorites that really jump out
yeah I do
um uh they're not in the book no uh
um they uh he's just looking at any one
of them right now what I really loved is
you have one of Norm Macdonald who we
lost over a year ago and I came to the
conclusion that it was the eyes and the
the the cheeks and you really nailed it
and now here over the commentary
something about Norm's eyes that were
mischievous yes almost like a Halloween
pumpkin that's like darting around he's
up to no good but there's also a kind of
benevolence there and like Conan
kneeland's son also has a favorite my
son was sitting on a chair the other
night
looking at all the paintings he was
sitting right in front of mine the one I
did it myself he goes this is my
favorite this is the best one you've
ever done
and I looked at I thought wow okay you
know Kneeland has been a creative Force
his entire career starting with
memorable characters and moments on SNL
like Mr subliminal thank you Dennis
haircut you know there's so many that
was my first sketch on SNL Donald and
Ivana Trump greedy pigs I mean and five
seconds away from first time I've ever
been on SNL
cameras are ready to go and Laura
Michaels comes up he puts his hand on my
shoulder he goes are you sure this is
what you want
[Laughter]
long time friend Dana Carvey Hans and
France we had to pop
and I remember the first time we did it
Dana and I we created those characters
because we heard him Schwarzenegger on
an interview
and we just talked like him for the next
couple of weeks grab you by the
jockstrom and give you the wedgie of
your life we took that one for a long
time I mean even Arnold wanted to be in
it and he eventually took the Helm of
Weekend Update a comedian's comedian
Kneeland has never stopped working in
television or on stage you know that's
neither here nor there
oh yeah well then where is it I've been
in the stand up over 40 years now and if
I never made it as a stand-up I'd
probably still be waiting in line at
open clock you know Open Mic nights at
different clubs because I just love it I
loved it it's all I ever wanted to do
was stand up and just like he did with
stand up the comedian continues to hone
this new craft I'm still kind of looking
it's like stand-up comedy when you start
off you're emulating somebody I'm still
looking for my own style is it helpful
at this point in your Evolution to
publish these as they are and and show
what you've been doing I think so
definitely I think this I'll look back
on this book and I'll think wow I was so
traditional here and I was so safe with
these and then with my style that I
would currently have which is hopeful
I'll say wow and this is what I've come
to this is what I've been seeking and no
matter what Kevin Nealon is seeking he
seems to find success by doing it his
I think it's it's interesting because
Kevin's a purist like he has very high
standards and I've never seen Kevin
compromise in his comedy the nice thing
about doing your own thing you don't
have to compromise you do what you want
to do you're looking at two people that
just are getting to do exactly what they
want to do and look at Kevin all all
through uh you know this terrible time
of covid he was making this and it's a
fantastic book it's a great output and
so that's a gift he gets to do that and
we get to enjoy it
we do enjoy it right it sounds great I
know and look at this you're going to
show it to us really quickly I will this
is one of the great honors of uh of my
life and that wow I got to join those
much more famous people
[Music]
so for those of you still with us I have
to say these are incredible and to know
that someone has that kind of talent
they could switch it on and off and he
loves it this is an honor because he
takes a month to a month and a half to
do every single painting like it's
really because you because the idea
behind a caricature is always you know
you get to know the personality right so
then you you accentuate something about
the person exactly that really is their
personality yes so to spend a little bit
I know
he missed the forehead but uh there is
something in the detail in in scrolling
through the book and looking at this he
really gets little details down that are
just amazing it does he really captures
the essence yeah that's what it is and
the eyes especially somehow there's a
sparkle that comes through in a lot of
them a sparkle would look nice with a
picture of us
Kevin if you've got this time but if you
have some spare time we'll send pictures
I just like when he talks about using it
to de-stress yeah oh yeah sitting on the
tarmac frustrated planes stuck and he
just starts drawing you know he goes
back to pickleball for me it was cooking
I think we all found something that
helped us during the pandemic that was
creative that contributed to the world
or our family but that really helped us
lose stress you know listening and
seeing some of the cliffs from SNL
though could he come back to SNL and do
some of those characters again I forgot
about subliminal man I won I would talk
about that you up I love it thank you so
much Jamie